[Narrator] Netflix has
released the final trailer
for season three of "Stranger Things."
It seems to confirm a possible fan theory
about the season's main villain
and includes more pop-culture references
from the '80s and early '90s.
Here are 11 details you might have missed.
First off, the trailer release.
The trailer came out at 7:11
p.m. Pacific Standard Time.
Perhaps the 7 is because the
new season debuts in July,
and 11 after...
Well, that seems obvious.
The trailer is set to the song
"Confrontation and Rescue,"
a Philip Glass song from the 1980s.
Eleven: It's building something.
[Narrator] The trailer starts
with an ominous voiceover.
Mind Flayer: You
let us in.
[Narrator] There's a good
chance this is the Mind Flayer,
aka the Shadow Monster,
who we first saw in season
two, which possessed Will,
taking a new human form.
Could it be Mayor Kline,
played by Cary Elwes?
Or could it be Billy?
More on that in a bit.
This all suggests that
while Eleven supposedly
closed the gate to the Upside
Down in the season two finale,
something ended up staying behind.
Will: What if he never left?
[Narrator] In another shot,
we see the gang preparing for a showdown.
We see Jonathan grab an ax
and Nancy cocking a gun.
Nancy is first seen with a
handgun back in season one.
She and Jonathan are
practicing in a field.
Nancy proves to be a natural,
hitting a can with her first shot.
Jonathan isn't so lucky,
which is maybe why he choose
to use an ax as a weapon.
She also carries a gun in season two.
We see Lucas inside the Starcourt Mall
practicing with a slingshot.
Slingshots are Lucas' weapon of choice.
In the season one finale, he
uses one against the Demogorgon
and actually gets a shot
in, with Eleven's help.
And speaking of the mall, as
we saw in the first trailer,
it will be a major
setting in season three.
In the background you'll spot
a number of 1980s brand logos,
including Burger King,
The Gap,
JCPenney,
and Orange Julius.
At the carnival, if you look closely,
you can see an old-school Coke logo.
At one point, we get a
quick glimpse of Will's arm.
On his wrist is a 1980s
Nelsonic Q-bert game watch.
As always, the show pays homage
to a lot of beloved pop
culture of the 1980s,
and this time the 1990s as well.
The Duffer brothers cited
1993's "Jurassic Park"
as a major influence on season three.
Some of the shots at the
mall are clear references
to this scene in which Tim and
Lex are hiding in the kitchen
from the velociraptors.
Speaking of early '90s references,
this new evil-looking
character is giving off
T-1000 vibes from 1991's "Terminator 2."
You might recognize him
as the guy with the gun
roaming through the hall of
mirrors in the previous trailer.
There's a brief shot of Billy's car
speeding towards the mall,
which seems to be a mirror
image of this DeLorean scene
in "Back to the Future."
This film was released in
1985, when season three is set,
and the scene happens to include
the same vintage JCPenney
logo we mentioned earlier.
At one point, we get another
glimpse of the Mind Flayer.
If you recall, in the
final shot of season two,
this creature was seen hovering
over Hawkins Middle School.
There also seems to be
hints that the Mind Flayer
will take another human form this season.
The question is who will
be the host this time?
Fans are speculating
that it could be Billy,
and this trailer is giving
us a few major hints
that this is true.
Will speculates that the monster
will attach itself to someone again.
As he says this, there's
a flash of the Mind Flayer
and an immediate cut to Billy.
Seconds later, we get a close-up shot
of Billy's dilating pupil.
The Brimborn Steel Works building
is also swarming with rats,
which tend to symbolize
some sort of outbreak,
so clearly someone is
going to be infected.
Was there anything we missed?
Let us know in the comments.